un tribunal de sentencia en honduras por
unanimidad de votos ha declarado
culpable a roberto castillo mejía como
coautor intelectual del asesinato de la
líder ambientalista berta cáceres hecho
ocurrido el pasado 3 de marzo del 2016
la individualización de la pena se
llevará a cabo el 3 de agosto del año en
curso cabe señalar que por este
asesinato ya fueron sentenciados siete
ciudadanos quienes guardan prisión y
fueron considerados autores materiales
de este crimen
honduras es considerado uno de los
países más peligrosos del mundo para
quienes se oponen a proyectos
extractivistas y eso fue lo que ocurrió
precisamente con berta cáceres quien se
opuso a la construcción de la represa
aguas cerca sobre el río walk arquette
bajo las órdenes de la empresa de esade
honduras del que david castillo era
precisamente el gerente general